bootleg cab we gotta run it back with my
guy that new album no matter what
OT the real no matter what let's go
let's go
[Music]
yeah
no matter what
all platforms Bullet Cab what up
to boil to the row look
they ain't in three days but they loving
the food you big homie got life I heard
he's [ __ ] with dudes yeah it's like I
was stuck in a Groove I was robbing
everybody I had something to prove on
the Move till all the Yoke was gone that
butter heart got him running in the park
cars like they chasing Pokemon this
ain't the line to get Social on I heard
they ripped your homies rolly off his
wrist and almost broke his arm work
fresh up off the steps I was fresh about
the nest fetty gave him the confused
face like they bout to guess
I get the paper now without the stress
Brody showed me how to re-rock without
the Press
microwave think of all the lives I
changed we was robbing put that mask on
I was banged
then his [ __ ] said I just came I
dropped her off and blew the horn like a
Vikings game don't ever think me and
these guys the same I really stood
outside and slain for everything that I
obtained hey
and you can put that to the fire flame
so crack I had to find the lane music
now it's time to change yeah look I
really had them grams before you had a
grand and that exotic's fun to smoke but
the Platt's a Wham and with the hassle
Fam I'm smoking cushion Castle bam
Philly block is jumping right [ __ ] looks
like a traffic jam good work no longer
hard to find they wrapped around the
block up early morning like the
Starbucks line y'all ain't got the
harder lines y'all Master the art of
line and I could see it bleeds through
every time you talk you trying they
booked my man buying Sudafed he beat the
case gave it back now he's in court
trying to sue the feds they couldn't
find a Seattle cause dude was dead bad
decisions lead the wig shots use your
head
no matter what
stop [ __ ] playing with me man
stop playing with me man hey hey put him
in the car
huh that [ __ ] is dead
it's Christ
that was amazing that's doing a bad [ __ ]
oh